bonjour à tous quel smartphone acheté
chez sun tzu en 2018 c'est une question
assez compliqué parce que vous avez
énormément de smartphone vous avez
quatre gammes vous avez 21 smartphones
alors quel smartphone samsung ht en 2018
et s'en va le regarder maintenant
quatre gammes chez samsung c'est
vraiment je crois le fabricant qui a le
plus de produits au catalogue la gabegie
l'entrée de gamme
la gamme a le moyen de gamme la gamme s
le haut de gamme et la gamme note qu' un
peu à part mais qui est à mon avis aussi
qui s'imbriquent avec le haut de gamme
en tout vous avez 21 smartphones je vous
ai fait déjà trois vidéos une vidéo sur
la gabegie l'entrée de gamme pour
reprendre vraiment vous expliquer qui a
été le produit à mon sens le plus
intéressant ou les produits les plus
intéressants à acheter la gamme à le
milieu de gamme quels sont les produits
les plus cools les plus sexy je vous ai
mis tout ça dans la description vous
pouvez aller voir et ensuite le haut de
gamme la gamme s et la gamme note pour
savoir quel smartphone haut de gamme htc
samsung alors dans l'absolu quel est le
meilleur produit
quel est le meilleur rapport qualité
prix htc samsung c'est pas si compliqué
que ça si on y regarde parce que même
dans l'entrée de gamme vous avez des
produits qui sont hyper sexy il ya une
vraie différence dans l'entrée de gamme
vous êtes au maximum sur des écrans hd
dans le milieu de gamme vous êtes sur
des écrans full hd
on peut dire ça comme ça et dans le haut
de gamme des écrans quad hd le fameux
écran infiniti kovar 3 notamment sur le
f8 s9 est également sur le note suite à
mon sens et des très bons produits dans
chaque gamme et dans chaque gamme
il y en a qui savent globalement a pas
grand chose dans l'entrée de gamme dans
la gamme jeep pour moi tous les produits
qui sont 2016
il faut pas les garder d'ailleurs dans
la gamme à c'est pareil pour moi
on les dégage on va mettre peut-être un
tout petit peu plus de budget d'avoir
des points qui sont très intéressants
pour moi dans l'entrée de gamme le j5 de
2017 est le meilleur produit le meilleur
rapport qualité prix
vous avez aussi le j 7 qui est bien si
vous avez besoin d'une double carte sim
mais sinon fondamentalement la
différence de prix se justifie pas entre
le j5 et j'essaie de 2017
je vous recommande très clairement
d'aller acheter le produit j-5 et de
2017 si vous voulez un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme un excellent rapport
qualité prix chez samsung
d'ailleurs si à un de ses produits qui
vous intéresse je vous ai mis tous les
liens dans la description ce sont des
liens d'affiliation non pas pour
m'enrichir si vous avez acheté par c'est
bien là mais pour pouvoir permettre de
continuer à développer la chaîne
d'acheter du matériel de l'est me rendre
à des événements des choses comme ça
donc n'hésitez pas si un de ces produits
vous intéresse à passer par les liens
d'affiliation et je vous en remercie par
avance ensuite dans la gamme à vous avez
également les produits de 2016 qui à mon
avis il faut pas conserver les produits
2017 sont plutôt cool
le produit que je trouve en tout cas le
plus intéressant c'est le a5 de 2017
parce que vous avez un super rapport
qualité prix par rapport au a3 qui est
assez bas génial génial et un autre
produit que je trouve vraiment très très
bien c'est le a8 de 2018 mais qui par
contre est beaucoup plus cher on est
légèrement en dessous des 500 euros mais
quand même 150 euros d'écart entre le a5
et le a8
c'est quand même un monde alors
effectivement on va très bien que le à 8
se positionne entre le milieu de gamme
et le haut de gamme
néanmoins il reste dans le milieu de
gamme mais pour voir qui est un milieu
de gamme il est quand même un peu plus
cher alors vous avez plein plein de
choses sur la photo fait des trucs et
qui sont vraiment extraordinaires double
caméra à l'avant avec une belle
profondeur de champ parce que voulait
faire une bonne porte clés vous avez les
autocollants vous avez plein de fiches
ya pas mal de possibilités pour moi
c'est un 8 il est hyper sexy d'ailleurs
vous ai fait plein de vidéos dessus je
vous mets aussi lire dans la description
maintenant en termes de budget aux
alentours de 350 euros à 5 de 2018 pour
moi fait fondamentalement vraiment la
faire mais aussi tout ce qu'on va aller
gratter un petit peu du côté du haut de
gamme le s6 pour moi je l'oubli parce
que je trouve qu un rapport qualité prix
il est quand même pas mal mais vous avez
vous rajoutez un peu d'argent vous avez
1 et 8 qui pour moi est beaucoup mieux
le s7 s8 s9 et note 8 sont vraiment les
produits que je garde dans les
préférences
j'élimine le s7 edge le s suit plus le
s9 plus simplement parce que si vous
allez acheter les suites plus vous aurez
le s9 quasiment au même prix et le spf à
prendre vraiment des innovations vu la
différence juste pour avoir une
différence d'écrans dont je pense que
voilà fondamentalement au lieu d'acheter
un esprit de plus aller acheter un ace 9
et vous serez vraiment beaucoup plus
content effectivement le s7 est
intéressant si vous vous fichez un petit
peu de l'écran
infiniti si le bord à bord c'est pas
votre dada le s est reste un super bon
produit pour faire des photos qui très
très bien si vous voulez pas acheter
tout fit le s9 parce que vous trouvez un
petit peu cher avec la photo avec un
double ouverture vous en fichez je l'aï
su était vraiment fantastique
l'écran infiniti est magnifique à tenir
dans les mains c'est un petit bijou
c'est un sucre produit et si vraiment
vous êtes un adepte de la photo alors là
le s9 vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés pour moi c'est le photophone de
cette année même si effectivement et de
très bons produits ailleurs pour la
photographie le no2 suite c'est un petit
peu à part le de suite c'est vraiment le
produit qui pour moi se destine aux gens
qui ont un réel besoin du style et parce
que le smartphone à un peu plus de 1000
euros si vous n'avez pas besoin du
espèce soit fondamentalement pas
l'intérêt ça coûte quand même très cher
vous a effectivement un produit qui est
grand si la gueule 3 pouces mais est ce
que ça vaut mille euros je suis pas sûr
mieux vaut avoir le 5,8 pouces du s9
audiosuite là avec l'écran fini tic est
vraiment magnifique pour moi quel est le
smartphone le plus sexy le plus
intéressant chez samsung
alors je peux pas vous dire il ya le
smartphone qui est le meilleur pour moi
très clairement dans l'entrée de gamme
il faut aller sur le j5 de 2017 dans
milieu de gamme le a5 2017 voire le a8
et ensuite se réfugie un coup de coeur
pour le s9 néanmoins le 7d suite très
très bien si vous voulez des bons
produits vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés
voilà un petit peu pour cette
rétrospective complète guide d'achat
pour savoir quel est le meilleur
smartphone de samsung ht en 2018 mark et
moi tous vos commentaires dites moi ce
que vous en pensez lequel vous trouvez
vous le plus cool le plus sexy qu'elle
produit vous voudriez avoir et qu'elle
produit vous ne voudriez pas à voir
quels produits vous avez eu lequel vous
a vraiment intéressé lequel vous a déçu
je vous invite comme à l'habitude de
marquer tout sans commentaire fou qu'on
puisse partager tous ensemble parce que
forcément des personnes qui roulent ses
produits et d'autres qui veulent les
acheter donc si tout le monde arrive un
peu à se connecter à donner son avis on
arrive ne pas faire avancer l'histoire
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
toutes ces vidéos vous invite comme
d'habitude à rester connectés à mes cd
jolie pousse à vous abonner parce que on
va faire toujours plus des comparatifs
comme ça pour vous aider concrètement
dans vos achats pour essayer de se
guider pas à pas je dis pas que c'est le
comparatif absolument tout cas c'est
vraiment comme ça que je les ressens et
c'est comme ça en tout cas que je les
perçois pour essayer de choper un peu
l'essence de tous ses modèles
merci à vous à très bientôt comme
d'habitude portez vous bien soyez sages
et à bientôt
[Musique]